Canada has been one of those countries
that has been the most steadfast with
Ukraine in my many conversations with
Ursula about the sanctions we've brought
in together the military support the
financial support that we've had over
the years every step of the way I've
stood up and said Canada will be there
with everything it takes for as long as
it takes to support Ukraine and I've
actually boasted
to her and to others that it's not a
political debate in Canada all parties
in Canada stand with
Ukraine so it is
particularly
troubling to see even though we are
seeing a rise of right-wing rhetoric in
the United States with Maga
conservatives uh across Europe in
certain corners of right-wing
politicians and
parties starting to pull their support
for
Ukraine starting to Parrot Russian
disinformation and misinformation and
propaganda that suddenly the
Conservative Party of
Canada would choose to not stand with
Ukraine in something that they need that
the Ukraine is asked
for and to use the frankly absurd
excuse that it's because Ukraine will be
bringing in a price on pollution in the
coming
years
obviously that's an
excuse but it's not the real
story the real story is the rise of a
right-wing American Maga influence
thinking that has made Canadian
conservatives who used to be among the
strongest Defenders of Ukraine I'll
admit it turn their backs on something
Ukraine needs in its hour of need that
is the danger of the rise of the
right-wing influence that is feeling its
impact in Canada that's what not just
Ukrainian Canadians but all Canadians
should be concerned about when the
Conservative Party of Canada and Pierre
POV turn their backs on History turn
their backs on our friends and allies
turns our back their backs on the
international rules-based order and our
support uh for the UN Charter and
territorial Integrity it is of real
concern and should be of concern to all
of us because we're seeing that spiking
up all around the world we voted against
Justin Trudeau forcing a carbon tax into
that pre-existing agreement
conservatives understand how devastating
the carbon tax has been for
Canadians it's caused 2 million people
to go to a food bank every single month
7 million Canadians not eating enough to
stay healthy we never had these problems
before Justin Trudeau and his costly
carbon tax now he wants to quadruple the
tax and just to show you how
pathologically obsessed Trudeau is with
his tax he did something that has never
been done in the history of trade
agreements which is to put a carbon tax
in one the people of Ukraine are now
going to he expects them to rebuild from
a war with a devastating and crippling
tax on their energy
the Ukrainian Farmers he expects them to
pay a carbon tax while they're trying to
feed their hungry
people this is cruel and frankly it is
disgusting